como síntoma del descontento
generalizado miles de haitianos salieron
a las calles del país para protestar en
contra de la creciente inseguridad y los
secuestros en la nación caribeña
las autoridades están ausentes así que
nosotros siendo abogados decidimos
marchar para expresar que estamos hartos
de que pasen estas cosas
numerosas ongs y grupos de la sociedad
civil convocaron la marcha en contra de
la inacción del gobierno contra las
bandas criminales que controlan en gran
parte de puerto príncipe la capital
muchos señalan en directamente al primer
ministro ariel en río por su mala
gestión
estamos acá para exigir ariel henrique
al director general de la policía que
hagan todo lo posible para garantizar la
seguridad del pueblo o dimitan a pesar
de que las manifestaciones
transcurrieron con calma en la capital
en los cayos al suroeste del país un
grupo de manifestantes prendió fuego al
avión de unos misioneros estadounidenses
país al que acusan de injerencia acción
rechazada por el gobierno
condeno enérgicamente la violencia de
los manifestantes que resultó en el
incendio de un avión en el aeropuerto de
los cayos y dado instrucciones a las
autoridades públicas para que pongan en
marcha acciones contra los autores de
estos actos subversivos para que sean
severamente sancionados
esta es la mayor movilización en haití
desde el magnicidio del antiguo
presidente joven el móvil en julio de
2021 y coincide con el 35 aniversario de
la constitución del país que lleva
registrando niveles de violencia y
delincuencia
alarmantes desde la muerte de mons